[Musique]
bonjour renaud gaudeul procureur de la
république en poste depuis le début de
l'année en début de semaine renaud
gaudeul une première pour notre île une
convention entre le parc et une mairie
celle de rivière salée
le maire salle ayant pourra désormais
faire des rappels à l'ordre aux citoyens
pour des factions pas trop grave mais
vous avez insisté sur une donnée
monsieur le procureur il faut d'une
réponse judiciaire rapide quelle que
soit la situation
c'est exactement ça je crois d'ailleurs
c'est l'intérêt de cette convention qui
va permettre de s'intéresser à des
infractions pour lequel actuellement
nous ne donnons aucune réponse pénale
c'est-à-dire en l'occurence des
infractions qui sont de toutes petites
importance pour lequel la justice n'a
pas les moyens n'a pas vocation
d'ailleurs forcément à y répondre de
manière directe avec des personnes qui
sont traduites devant le tribunal
correctionnel vous allez trouver les
moyens de désengorger cette justice et
c'est à peu près ça c'est en tout cas
c'est c'est l'idée l'idée c'est de dire
ces petites infractions là elle ne
relève pas du tribun correctionnelle
mais pourtant il faut quand même lui
donner une réponse pénale parce que si
on y donne pas une réponse pénale et
bien les auteurs de ces toutes petites
infractions se disent je peux commettre
ces petites infractions sans qu'il y ait
la moindre réponse est par conséquent
bien je peux continuer et je continue
dans cette graduation et on en arrive à
des situations beaucoup plus grave et là
seulement la justice agit et là l'idée
c'est de dire on va intervenir au plus
près de la commission de la première
infraction quelle que soit sa gravité et
chaque maire de martinique deviendra
quelques par un procureur local
chaque maire de la république s'il le
veut car ce n'est en aucun cas une
obligation ici s'intéresse à la question
si légalement il est véritablement
impliqué dans une politique de
prévention de la délinquance à cette
possibilité donc de contacter le
procureur public et ensuite de mettre en
place cette organisation qui lui permet
d'agir vous souhaitez que d'autres
maires que ordre et lotions de maire de
rivière salée et adopte cette démarche
je suis absolument ouvert à toute
démarche en ce sens là dès lors qu
encore une fois ça nous permettra de
donner ces réponses pénales a défait que
qui pour l'instant ne sont pas très une
réponse rapide et des délais de
traitement de dossiers encore plus
efficace c'est à lune
des priorités annoncées en début d'année
au moment de votre arrivée
pourquoi le traitement de ces dossiers
peut paraître aussi long sur le
procureur alors je crois en premier lieu
quand on part d'une situation qualité il
faut le dire quand même très dégradée il
ya encore quelques années et avec une
évolution considérable dans le bon sens
depuis le voit en cours de ces dernières
années avec me semble t'il en tout cas
en tout cas moi c'est le constat que je
fais en arrivant ici une un traitement
des dossiers les plus graves dans les
délais qui sont beaucoup plus rapides
que ceux qui est qui qui étaient les
leurs il ya encore quelques années
donc il ya une véritable amélioration et
je crois en tout cas de mon point de vue
un traitement tout à fait adapté de ces
infractions les plus graves
même si on peut encore évidemment se
perfectionner s'agissant de ces délais
maintenant je crois que l'objectif c'est
également de mordre sur ces infractions
alors alors on parle plus de ce rappel à
l'ordre d'évoquer tout à l'heure mais
sur ces infractions de moyenne
importance et sur lesquels la
effectivement jours en arrière et
séquences sélectionnées une fracture
d'un modèle important ça va être un vol
par un vol avec violence mais un vol
simple parce qu'on appelle juridiquement
un vol simple ça va être
des infractions quotidien des
martiniquais absolument je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous c'est
exactement ça ce sont ces infractions la
ccja voilà deux mots que l'ong était de
la justice de sa crédibilité auprès des
usagers
certainement mais vous avez raison et
encore une fois c'est bien pour ça que
pour moi c'est c'est une des mes
priorités c'est de mettre en place un
système qui nous permettent de répondre
à ces faits là certainement pas
systématiquement avec des poursuites
devant le tribunal correctionnel parce
que si je le fais et bien là pour le
coup je vais engorgé la juridiction et
la juridiction paradise et les lotions
et non parce qu'il n'ya plus aujourd'hui
ça c'est un schéma qui est un petit peu
dépassé aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vous avez ce qu'on appelle
les réponses alternatives aux poursuites
il dans les réponses alternatives aux
poursuites devant le tribunal
correctionnel vous avez notamment des
mesures d' ordonnance pénale des mesure
de composition pénale une mesure de
composition pénale c'est le fait en
l'occurrence de confier à ce qu'on
appelle un délégué du procureur
la mission autorisée par un juge du
siège de sanctionner la personne sur sur
un certain nombre d'infractions ça fait
sur les conditions plainte alcoolique
encore une fois sur des vols sur des
petites même si j'aime pas trop ce terme
en tout cas des violences de moyenne
gravité
il vient pour ces infractions là on peut
tout à fait en l'occurrence les réprimer
en confiant ces dossiers là à des
délégués le procureur et par conséquent
dans les délais beaucoup plus rapide et
les victimes qui voient concrètement
quelle est la réponse qui est ainsi
donnée
vous avez donc déjà identifié quelques
leviers pour fluidifier les choses
comment juger comment jauger cette
perception de la justice par les
citoyens vous en avez les moyens par
exemple vous monsieur monsieur godel on
parlait de cette perception qu'on peut
avoir de de la justice c'est trop long
c'est trop lent oui oui alors il y a des
moyens alors haut niveau au niveau
national il ya des enquêtes qui sont
déjà parus notamment je pense au moment
de la du lancement du projet dit de
justice du 21e siècle où il y avait eu
effectivement une enquête assez globale
sur ce sujet là il faut dire ce qui est
effectivement ce qu'ils reprochaient par
les citoyens ici comme ailleurs ce sont
les délais
de la justice qui sont considérés comme
trop lents c'est également la complexité
de la justice qui est également reproché
à l'institution judiciaire
ensuite ici sur le terrain il faut aussi
je crois être sur le terrain
il faut aussi avoir rencontré des
personnes et pour se rendre compte de
cette insatisfaction mais qui n'est pas
non plus une insatisfaction si global
que cela je crois quand même que
les décisions qui sont rendus sont le
plus souvent accepté même si encore une
fois on y revient toujours
il ya cette question des délais sur
lequel on doit s'améliorer monsieur le
procureur nous sommes dans les jours qui
précèdent le carnaval périodes
présentées comme étant délicate avec la
sécurité routière
la consommation d'alcool cette opération
déposer les armes troisième édition
beaucoup doutent de celle ci car basée
essentiellement sur le volontariat
que doit-on on attendre en toute
franchise je peux certain que beaucoup
de personnes en dotant en tout cas ce
qu'il ya une certitude c'est que les
précédentes éditions où intime
semble-t-il quand même couronné de
succès lorsqu'on avait plus de mille
armes qui sont ainsi déposé et qui par
conséquent ne seront jamais ça en tout
cas me larmes qui ne serviront jamais à
commettre des actes violents à commettre
d homicide dire qu on doute de cette
opération la trouvaient trop sévère et
des verts cette édition 2010 est aux
armes blanches
absolument oui enfin non là l'objectif
principal quand même clairement ce sol
et ce soleil ce sont les armes à feu je
pense que parce que possible monsieur
monsieur le poker vous pensez
franchement que je n'ai par exemple qui
s'apprête à découvrir le carnaval
semaine prochaine à fort de france avec
qui part déjà avec l'idée d'une arme à
feu sur lui il a déposé son arme avant
d'entrer dans le vide et et bien je veux
dire très clairement non mais cette
opération là elle s'adresse pas à ces
personnes ont durci je dirais dans une
délinquance en sûrs si c'est pas ça la
cible la cible ce sont les personnes qui
à un moment donné ou à un autre aux
acquis ou se sont retrouvés en
possession d'une arme et ces personnes
là qui au bout d'un certain temps ou de
quelques années deux trois quatre ans
voire plus peu importe se disent bon
effectivement j'ai cette arme
je n'ai plus aucune intention de m'en
servir et par conséquent je ne sais pas
quoi en faire
je ne sais pas quoi en faire et bien
trop souvent à ces personnes là je suis
par conséquent les concerts exactement
les bas c'est ça le danger c'est ensuite
ces personnes qui conserve césar n'a
peut-être que l effectivement que jamais
à s'en servir mais cette arme avait
trouvé un moment donné et quelqu'un va
quelqu'un mal intentionnés va en faire
un mauvais usage et c'est ça la cible et
c'est ça que l'on veut éviter la
sécurité routière 26 morts à l'an
dernier 29 l'année précédente
ces comportements l'alcool procureur
peut dire faire quelque chose devant par
exemple cette déferlante publicitaire
que nous voyons sur les panneaux où la
consommation d'alcool approche du vide
et alors c'est pas tant sur ce point là
que l'on peut en tout cas nous a procuré
pouvons pouvons agir en revanche sur
cette répression quand à la quant à la
consommation de l'alcool et ou de drogue
à bord de véhicules ou sur des os sur
des deux roues motorisés là où il a il
faut agir
c'est une certitude de la manière
d'ailleurs qu' il faut agir s'agissant
de de comportement routier qui ne sont
pas admissibles qui mettent en danger
les autres et sur lesquels la hausse il
doit y avoir une réponse non seulement
ferme mais je dirais rapide
encore une fois on y revient mais là
aussi je crois que c'est une question de
crédibilité
il dresse à peine deux minutes renaud
gaudeul parlant du trafic international
de drogue
ce phénomène des mules qui semble
prendre énormément d'importance
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ça
c'est d'abord de la prévention c'est
d'abord de l'information de la
sensibilisation tout à fait absolument
dr je trouve intéressant que vous
évoquez cet aspect là des choses parce
qu'il y à la répression les abus voire
quand même que me semble-t-il était
assez dissuasive vous avez vu que ces
personnes là sont aussi poursuivis
systématiquement son la procédure de
comparution immédiate est que
systématiquement sur les personnes qui
se retrouvent un quart simple pour que
soit leur casier judicaire dire ce sont
des victimes de la crise économique des
personnes qui sont dans un état
d'extrême pauvreté
peut-être financièrement peut-être
psychiquement et qui se trouve là
peut-être moyen de s'en sortir comme
c'est le cas en amérique latine voilà
alors juste là aussi s'intéresse assez
vite comme c'est le cas en amérique
latine je crois qu'il faut il faut
distinguer vous avez le phénomène des
mules tel qu'on peut le connaître par
exemple en guyane qui n'est pas du tout
le phénomène de mule tel que nous
l'avons ici en martinique en guyane
éventuellement ce que vous dites peut
être audible ici je ne dis pas que ce
soit totalement inaudible mais je crois
pas que ce soit l'explication
essentielle
je crois en l'occurrence que même si
encore une fois je vais pas vous dire
sans les personnes qui roulent sur l'or
qui commettent ces faits l'est
évidemment pas le cas mais en
l'occurrence quand même des personnes
qui sont appâtés par le gain d'un gain
qui n'est pas négligeable il y en a de
plus en plus ça ça mériterait encore
d'être d'être d'être confirmés mais en
l'occurrence en tout cas il est bien
certain que c'est un sujet prioritaire
mais sur lequel nous devons nous
coordonner
s'agissant de la réponse avec les
procureurs de guadeloupe et de la guyane
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
dans son crédit en oeuvre des lois
telles que vous êtes procureur de la
république en poste depuis le début de
l'année bonne journée
etc